the Democrat in the special
congressional election in western
Pennsylvania is claiming victory but the
race is still razor thin as of this
morning Democrat Connor Lam is six
hundred and forty one votes ahead of
Republican Rick ciccone there are still
around 1000 absentee provisional and
military ballots that need to be counted
Nancy Cordes is in Pittsburgh following
the tight race for the US House seat
Nancy good morning good morning things
are still in a state of flux here the
Democrat Connor Lam declared victory at
about 1:00 a.m. and his campaign does
not believe that the Republican Rick
Ciccone can make up the difference with
the small amount of absentee ballots yet
to be counted but Ciccone is not
conceding he said he's fighting until
the end and his campaign tells us that
it is exploring all legal options to
make sure that every vote has been
counted fairly still what's rocking the
political world this morning is the fact
that we are seeing a razor tight finish
in a district that president Trump won
by 20 points at where he campaigned for
Ciccone twice national Republicans are
blaming the candidate one GOP operative
telling CBS News that ciccone who is a
four-term state representative quote
didn't know how to run a race like this
and was out of his league but it must be
said his opponent is a 33 year-old
first-time candidate himself and
Democrats say that it's a sign that the
president's low approval ratings are
going to be a drag on his party come
November especially because there are
more than 100 GOP controlled
congressional districts that are more
competitive than this one has been Nora
in recent years it's a good point Nancy
thank you so much